[Music]
there's a theater festival up in
massachusetts uh called williamstown it
attracts a lot of wealthy manhattanites
who are vacationing and i was driving
around once with
sam rockwell and philip seymour hoffman
i had this farting app i plugged it into
my speakers and i would crank it up and
i would stop and ask these wealthy
people and khakis and salmon shirts
where you know the theater was and they
would say um i think it's over and then
i would and they started raising their
voices to you know give me the
directions over the farts
uh it's it's so
it's the eternal left here
rarely have i heard two people laugh as
hard as phil and sam were laughing in
the back seat i mean obviously they had
ducked down you know if these people had
seen them they would have seen two of
america's greatest actors cracking up
over farts
from wondering this is justin long and
you are listening to life is short life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
here as always with my brother christian
yes hello everybody a man a man that
i've known for 37 years i don't know why
it's so weird to me that you referred to
me as a man i don't think you've known
that before i've never had i literally
don't care when it came out of my mouth
ever referred to me as a man but i don't
know why that's weird because i'm
certain i'm a man but oh thanks like a
man when i think of a man i feel like a
bouncy like a manly man yeah
not all men have to be manly man mr
clean
that's what you think of for a man well
like a
like a lumberjack like a shiny cartoon
you're like bald i understand you're
with masculinity now
okay i'm not a manly man but i'm a man
regardless i shouldn't be surprised that
you referred to me well you've never
called me a man i know
i don't think of myself as a man this is
a much bigger problem
so every week we're going to unravel
problems like this
so this
very special interview uh was actually
the very first one we recorded so we'll
always hold a special place in our
hearts
sam is someone that we chose as the
first guest because
of how well we know him and how
comfortable we are with him and we
thought that would be
much easier and
comfortable comfortable sam has also
been a part of um he was in the first
movie i did he was in the first
professional play i did he
chris and i wrote a movie a couple years
ago and he was in that i mean he's been
he's part of your first sexual
experience that's right that's right he
was in my first fivesome
um sam has been a friend of mine a very
dear friend of mine for uh over she's
over 20 years now and um he was kind
enough to do this obviously before it
was a show
before it was a thing at all and so
he didn't have to do it he's now at a
point in his career where he can do
anything he wants and um
i just really appreciated him coming on
and he showed up looking very gaunt and
bald oh yeah you hadn't seen him in
there i hadn't seen him so he was
shooting fosse verdin on fx um so i was
immediately thrown off by how different
he looked what did he look like you said
he looked like uh i don't know he heard
her like that he always looks a little
bit like a bird he just looked like a
thinner bird like a plucked
he looked very plucked and tiny but he
always looks different i mean that it
kind of made sense to me that oh he's
playing bob fosse in this thing and he
looks like a totally different person
because that's what he does yeah right
yeah i mean he's uh
he's a chameleon i know i hate to use it
but it applies it really does apply and
i now can't wait as his friend for many
reasons i can't wait till he plays like
mario batali or somebody um because
mario batelli's comeback story
or his demise story um
they'll cover everything in the
battalion biopic but uh it'll be fun to
watch him eat a lot and to and to just
see him as a as a heavy person
and so the difficulty in interviewing
him was that so much of what we share is
personal is kind of like
nights out and drinking and you know my
perspective is that i've i've been out
with you guys and i've seen
people come up to you
and kind of treat you like a zoo animal
and and like a piece of me and they're
like oh you're the guy from waiting and
they you're gonna get a picture and
they're kind of like hostile like
aggressive sometimes and then and then
with him they're like
i'm sorry to bother you i i'm i'm a huge
fan of your work
keep on keep on like providing the
world with your art you know and with
you it's like a selfie
so he's hustling my hair yeah he's
always been he's i would say he's always
been like a
cool respected yeah obviously gifted
actor but now it's weird in the last
year or two since he's he's become this
like mainstream like award-winning
oscar-winning
um good actor which um
so we're
going to talk to him about that yeah if
that change changed um a testament to
his character and who he is as a person
as a friend is that he he from my
perspective has remained unchanged
throughout all of this all the hoopla
you know all the award stuff and now
becoming
uh like our gary oldman
that's great and he's um spoiler alert
he's great and
bossy verdin bob fosse the famous
choreographer from the 50s 60s 70s and
we will talk about his career his whole
career from box moonlight to uh his most
recent role is w in vice and we'll talk
about roles that he didn't take which i
always think is interesting with those
great actors i was nervous as hell doing
this um but i'm i'm excited for you to
hear it we'll be right back with sam
rockwell right after the break
okay so
we're rolling with this we can cut all
this down bulge
well based on that sentence you all know
my guest is sam rockwell
and uh
that's a classic sam rockwell sentence
what kind of
job actually this this guy down at the
this this uh gym i get he's he started
he says we should bring bull drive back
i didn't i don't know if it was ever
there but i like it i didn't know it was
a thing ever i like it let's make it a
thing what does it mean bowl jack like
bull roar like [ __ ] yeah like
[ __ ] but [ __ ] we can curse on
this right
yeah okay i'm getting the thumbs up i
don't know but i like it [ __ ] undies
and i like anything 70s my mom the other
day said uh you're so excited your ass
is gonna water
she said it sarcastically really good i
like that what does that even mean
i don't know and i said to her what i
said that very thing what does that mean
she's like you you know that's the thing
you used to say all the time
and i said
i've never i've never heard those words
together i'm and she said it
sarcastically like oh yeah i'm so
excited my ass is going to water that's
amazing
she said you know i mean like you have
the runs or what does that mean i've
never thought of having a watery ass is
a good thing
um but i've known you for about 20 years
and uh but i guess
20 years is it more than 20 yeah it'll
be 20 this year april's uh no it'll be
20 galaxy quest we shot in the fall
what was it is that 20 is that 20 years
fall of 1999 summer of 1999 and
so what
that's when i and i had heard people
talking about you i remember on the way
to set you know of course tim allen and
sigourney weaver were people that i knew
but um i remember hearing your name and
actors i just dropped out of school so i
was around a lot of young actors and
faster that vassar yeah uh so i but i
so everybody was kind of talking about
you and and um but i was of course
excited to see
sigourney weaver and these big stars you
know and uh
and you were the one guy on the set that
really
took me under your wing and and i could
like relate to and we would yeah we
became pals but but we're close enough
in age right that it was
yeah that that it was cool it was like
it made sense
yeah also i wasn't i didn't know you
then and then i got to know you and then
we did a play about a year later and um
during that time i watched boxing
moonlight and lawn dogs and safe men and
i really um i became a fan so we were
friends initially and and then i wanted
to know all these things that i guess i
never asked you so now i can ask you uh
when you did
box of moonlight would you say that was
the first
uh was that the first the moment that
you felt like oh now i can be an actor
and i'm no longer yeah that was the one
of the first jobs after
delivering burritos on a bicycle i guess
that was well no i didn't i was in new
york i was in new york
and i i got in this car accident i
messed up my hand
and we were waiting for the money
and i was instead i was doing restaurant
jobs but i was starting to do more
commercials and movies and i was
starting to get work
episodics law and order and then i
waited a long time for them to get the
financing finally got john deturo
yeah that yeah that led to jerry and tom
movie assault rubinick and that led to
safeman and that led to lawn dogs huh
okay i was gonna do gi jane and i
dropped out of the boot camp uh because
it was just getting just i just had to
get out of there and it was intense boot
camp it wasn't no it was fun actually
but i was at that time
very skinny i had no body fat and they
were we were in the water and i was like
i was just i just couldn't handle the
cold i was just couldn't handle the
water
and um i was like oh this is gonna suck
what was
for a long time i missed my girlfriend
at the time sarita and um are those
parts
are they appealing in in
yeah
i not really i don't find it's just a
taco with a bunch of dudes really
in getting montezuma's revenge i mean i
like hanging out with a bunch of dudes
but i don't love traveling i'm not a big
truck are you a big traveler yeah i like
to travel i like the the gypsy lifestyle
like living out here i like it less now
than i did when i was my 20s that was
the but if you go to australia it's got
to be a good part right it's gonna or if
somebody says south africa you're like
yeah it doesn't matter what part is see
if it were a war film then you think
like i just imagine you wait around for
like three weeks and then you do yeah a
day where you're like get down and yeah
phil and phil and steve zahn and i used
to joke about the spin red line
philharmonics
steve zahn
and we were all up for that and i
remember phil said
he said yeah
i don't know about that one like if you
show up for that one you want to go all
the way like you want to have a big you
want to really you want to let your bit
you want to be in every frame when i met
justin he did the most amazing phil
hoffman impersonation
and mark wahlberg in boogie nights and i
made him do it in front of phil at a
mexican restaurant called el compadre
after we saw what was that shark movie
we saw deep blue sea yeah we saw deep
blue sea with so this is an example of
how yeah you i didn't know anyone really
in la and you invited me out i mean it
seems like a simple thing now but like
you were just like hey hey man well you
were adorable you wanna go you wanna go
see i was eager you know i was like i'll
be a good friend you were so star struck
by phil because you had just yeah boogie
nights yeah i was i was obsessed with
phil and phil was uh god
he was he really was and he and he still
is and you didn't give me any he still
is you know he's our he's our guy yeah
you know yeah but i remember when he
showed up that day and you didn't really
give me any warning he was wearing like
a i think he was wearing a like an
almond brothers band sure i remember it
really clearly oh at this movie at the
cinema yeah he's like
i think you said as you often do because
you're not
a name you'll drop you don't drop names
like this is a fans where you're just
like that's fine
well you do only when you're on podcasts
uh but you were like my friend phil
is coming and you know phil and i
and i had to kind of get it out of you
that and i freaked out and when he
showed up that's phil hoffman holy [ __ ]
it was like here was a guy who yeah i
looked up to and all that and we went to
see this movie it's kind of a dumb movie
that shark movie and uh tim allen was
laughing you know and and then phil
would laugh every time tim laughed and
it was
so i found myself just watching phil and
tim and they were making each other
laugh because they were laughing at how
bad it was that's right and then yeah
you're right we went out to el compadre
afterwards and and sam did the thing
that you do with me often which is so
you've set me up for impressions uh
which i love doing um and you had me do
it for phil and when i first and i was
too
i was too chicken [ __ ] to do it when you
first did it uh when you said hey phil
you guys he does a great impression of
you
it's awesome oh my god and so
yeah so okay so the
the the fill impression was yeah i do
remember what it was it was it was mark
wahlberg and him in boogie night it was
that scene yeah uh where he gets the car
where phil gets the car and he wants to
impress yeah
he ends up crying in the car so you know
when i did [ __ ] idiot fight
[ __ ]
yeah
but when it was
so good but i remember when i did it i
so i was afraid to do it at first and
then we were drinking so much tequila i
know uh to the point where i just i
launched into it unsolicited i remember
you were like i came out of nowhere and
i was just like all right i'll do it
yeah i'll do it and i started i just
started the impression are you missing
my car jerk
like i would make sure you liked it
right he was like stone-faced wasn't he
he was everybody at the table was
laughing and phil was kind of
stone-faced and years later he claims he
he claimed he wasn't he he said no i
thought it was funny you know but at the
time i remember him saying that's just
me from boogie nights that's not how i
talk
and and and then i i to redeem myself i
remember doing because phil is very
close to
he's very close to ted levine when chad
levine it's like uh same register was
she a great big fan person
you put the lotion is that ted levine in
silence of the lambs or is that the vein
all the time i think that's ted lavina
science of the world have you heard ted
levine and other things i have i've
worked with him yeah i'm trying to think
it's a little bit like
i mean a little bit i'd have to go back
i saw him do a movie called georgia with
jennifer jason lee and he i saw it right
after silence glam and he plays like a a
very kind of like um benign stay-at-home
dad right that's his part
and it's so creepy because he's got
lines up there's the [ __ ] out of here
yeah cause he's like yeah listen i i put
ginny and ginny to bed early um because
she didn't eat her dessert and um and
tommy was able i read him a bedtime
story and i tucked him in and it's like
oh get away did you send me the the
science of lamb's lego
uh put it in the basket song did you say
that maybe i played it for him oh really
he never heard it he loved it oh he's
laughing his ass off and uh so he's okay
with that buffalo bill he's totally cool
he knows you know it's it's it's sort of
i'm sure it haunts him a little bit he i
actually he was in jesse james too and
single shot that's right and he's a
great guy and we had to flip this calf
in single shot
and he was able to do it i think i was
only able to do it like maybe once
and he was because he lives on a farm oh
wow so he's he's that guy yeah
he i had heard that he couldn't get work
for a while after it signs the limits is
that true yeah that's what i had heard
but you and then he was on monk and uh
so jesse that's right he was in jesse
james yeah he got type cast probably
yeah do you remember there's i i
remember dropping you off
for the audition
for jesse james my brother and i dropped
you off yeah i'll never forget because
what was i doing this is one of the you
know one of the great actors uh and he's
um you're running across sunset because
sam doesn't yeah it's safe to say you
don't drive that's fair to say right
it's a fast oh yes yes i i know i drive
i drive my i i um
you drive your girlfriend crazy
but i drive i drive in films and stuff i
don't drive because all right you're a
city you're only driving films but uh
yes yes so you're able to drive i i know
how to drive i i don't know how to drive
a stick shift i don't think i've ever
i had a license for for a long time um
but like we're good good friends
i've known you for 20 years i probably
cut that part out because then they
won't let me drive no okay all right
i still need to make a living driving
and filming but i've never driven in a
car with you this is strange we've known
each other at over 20 years i've never
uh yeah i only drive
uh the moment i'm paid for it okay but
so but so we were picking you up as and
before uber you relied um on taxis and
friends yeah uh so we were we were uber
and you and um happy to do it but i
remember you
scammering across the street and you had
like
you had like cowboy like kids cowboy get
up like yeah like toy cowboy gear did i
have like squirt guns
yeah yeah you had like a red i think
like red yeah yeah yeah little
peashooters and i didn't get that part
oh you didn't get that part i got
another party that's right then they
wanted you for another but that's a good
example of the part you're playing then
is not maybe not on paper the showiest
part the flashiest part but i think
that's what people connect to with a lot
of your work you're able to make these
people these kind of
things you know maybe less desirable on
the surface parts really human and and
um
uh that's something i want to make out
yeah uh this is we can by the way that
we're not being filmed
um you work harder than anybody i i know
that i've seen
what is it like so when when you did
that um when you do any part i mean what
do you how do you approach it what is
your
uh i i've seen a lot of scribbles
well you know i think that you've you've
trained as an actor and i've trained as
an actor i did meisner training and and
um you know it's like and we've done
theater and that's the training in
itself
and
you know i think that
the training really
informed because i was just kind of
[ __ ] around until i was in william
esper and then i and that was when you
were in your 20s in my 20s 91 and then i
started i was doing some theater and
and then i just did the meisner training
for two years and that and i met terry
there and maggie flanagan these two
teachers there and bill was an amazing
teacher
and that was like the the buds training
for me and then so to speak and then um
it went on you know and from there i
think
i stayed working with terry and so i was
able to still work with the same coach i
mean this is yeah i work with terry
nickerbacher he's a meisner coach and he
he was uh one of william esper's
proteges now he has his own school and
maggie flanagan was the same i i trained
with her a little bit so that so the
work itself is just uh
yeah i need structures yeah i i lay out
times where i can read it out loud i i
tape my lines i go to see terry i go i
face time with liz right now i'm doing
this this tv thing where i got to play a
real person and i'm so you're doing bob
fosse playing bob fosse and that's very
there's a lot involved with hair and
makeup and
does that get in the way is that the
challenge it's it's a challenge for me
as i'm a very fidgety person and so in
the hair and makeup chair it's it's
tricky the the most daunting was george
bush because huh he's so famous so
everybody everybody has an opinion of
reference what he sounds like yeah like
elvis presley or marilyn monroe or you
know nobody sounds nobody knows what abe
lincoln sounds like
um nobody knows it's true so how did you
go about that then was it a matter of
and not making an impression
i think that the thing that you see when
you see
people who play real people very well
you know
i think the main thing you're seeing
that has to penetrate through the
impression is the truth
the intention of the scene and the heart
and soul of the of the actor
has to punch through the impression if
that makes sense yeah i i feel like if
you just see the impression you're lost
did that inform how you approached bush
i mean did you approach him as an
anti-hero or well i just think that the
movies that i grew up on the the the
heroes were incredibly flawed you know
the deer hunter
and sophie's choice you know raging bull
these are all very flawed people you
know and so but they're heroic and
they're also very flawed and so i think
that that's interesting you know with
bush did you talk to him were you able
to was it just a matter of watching a
lot of um footage
did you have an opinion about him that
you used i i i just i found him um
very charming i was surprised yeah
charming i found him and and um you know
i really
thought he was just a guy who was in
over his head
with these master politicians yeah yeah
you know
that sort of struck me
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
there are a lot of questions about
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy on
twitter people want to know you know
about the two i love that movie it's a
weird movie but approaching a part like
that how different is it from oh man
doing like because that's like a you
could see that's like a wacky comedy
whatever yeah yeah that was really
eclectic i mean i remember watching
george bush
bill clinton uh matthew mcconaughey oh
yeah mcconaughey he was in this vaughn
yeah a little bit of woody harrelson and
then i remember watching freddie mercury
and um
i feel like there's a little brad pitt
in there
but the one thing um
i watched jim carrey in the mask oh
right a lot and i watched some will
ferros i mean i watched everything
people who were that those seem to be
all people who were like untamed like
they don't have any structure uh yeah so
and then that other head was a little
bit more
pragmatic and eddie murphy in uh the
nutty professor ah huh his alter ego
i think is really i've stolen a lot from
that that
a couple of times when i did better
living through chemistry i watched the
nutty professor i watched the jerry
lewis one
and eddie murphy so i st i steal a lot
of [ __ ]
from from the boyd's deal from the past
from the greats you know bill murray
richard pryor eddie murphy
you know de niro you know john boyd i
always say that young students i say you
know
watch
the men should watch the women and the
women should watch the men yeah that if
you're a young actress huh you should
watch raging blue if you're a young
actor you should watch sophie's choice
interesting bob hoskins why said
something about about if you want to
play a tough guy my teacher said this
too
bob hoskins said he would watch you know
he he was more interested in and and
women when he was watching um
there's a i don't know there's something
about
um tapping into that vulnerability
if you're a tough guy
underneath that i think is all these
kinds of that's what gene hackman was
great at too you know yeah
and i i think that's something that my
teacher said once and and i never forgot
to
and you know gene hackman always also
said um
i try to find the simplest way to tell
the story and what i start with how am i
similar
to this guy
start with that huh and then
whatever i'm not with whatever is not
similar then you got to make that part
again you got to fill that in you know
so how were you similar
to bush
well i'm not i'm not a southerner and i
play all these these texans and and i
had done a texas accent and uh so that i
wasn't worried about you mentioning a
lot of these movies that you grew up
with and and i know christopher walken
has been like a big part of he's been a
big influence for you
uh in fact when i met you um
i i knew that i knew that early on that
he was a a big part of your
big part of the reason why
you're an actor and um men he meant a
lot to you uh will you favor us with the
story of because i get it wrong when i
tell it yeah you stayed sam stayed next
door to
chris walken at the chateau and you in
an attempt to meet him is this possible
to tell yes yes yes so we were in the in
the elevator
and um
well wouldn't they call you because
wouldn't walking call down to the
kitchen
he called down to get milk for his cats
or something or i i had heard he was
getting milk for he had i heard he
travels with like 20 cats
i've since become friends with him yeah
and i don't think this stuff is true but
i we were down it was ivan my friend
ivan and catherine his girlfriend and we
were there's a balcony that shares with
another room another balcony and i would
go to look sam was in like a corner room
and on the on the other corner room that
um next door it had a wraparound balcony
right yes yes and so i would sometimes
peek onto the part of the balcony which
was not my balcony to get a view of
sunset boulevard
and and kind of check out what's going
on downstairs and
and sometimes i would just look to see
if there was anybody in there so i could
go over to their balcony and then i s
when i saw the silhouette
that looked like you know count dracula
or something in the neighbor's room
in the neighbor's room and did you know
that he was staying there
i feel like i might have known i i
quickly walked away and went back to my
part of the balcony the next day there
was a cat box dividing the two balconies
as to as to be
two balconies instead of one so it was
clear that someone put those litter
boxes yeah separately okay saw him and
we ended up getting an elevator with him
we rode the elevator and we tried to
sort of
be kind of cool about it and then we
we were like it's a very small elevator
and then i said something like he said
to me
i don't know he wouldn't probably
remember this but you didn't bring it up
with him i haven't talked to him about
this story but he said
because we did a play together in a film
together and we're now friends and and
this is way before way before that
and um he said um
there was a long silence and ivan and
catherine and i were just trying to be
cool and be like don't don't don don't
say anything don't say anything don't
don't blow it don't blow it you know
we're in the elevator with chris walker
in the other one
and that's what we're thinking and
there's a long sentence and he goes
i put the cat box outside so
it the cats don't get out and i almost
felt like he was trying not to hurt my
feelings or something
like he was saying that's for the cats
that's not so you won't come on my
balcony oh i see i see that wasn't this
off yeah but
no so i i was like so i i went oh yeah
you have a lot of cats don't you have
like you travel with a lot of cats like
like 20kgs
no
and then i was like
there's another long silence and then we
we were
i think it was very awkward but then
we got out of the elevator and we walked
and catherine and ivan and i walked
behind him but we were going the same
way uh-huh yeah we had already said bye
because he said the elevator goes okay
okay bye and then he kept he kept
walking and of course we're going in the
same direction that's an awkward thing
you don't want to like satisfy again
you've already used they don't say bye
again so i tried to make funny and i
said uh so if the if the cats get out
should i get like a net or something and
he went ah no
and they walked in that's pretty much
the story
that was the first time i had
interactions with the great chris watkin
yesterday and that now that it's as
you've worked with him so much and
you've become so close to that
now he
you know he just called you guys hang
out which i'm still
still can't believe um were you able to
tell him what what he meant to you
growing up and what a big influence he
was i think in that you know we had this
ten minutes uh backstage where he i was
going on and he was leaving and we would
sort of read the newspaper and hang out
together and we would talk about stuff
and he would tell some great stories and
um
one day we're having a coffee break
and martin mcdonough is there and zoe
kazan anthony mackie were hanging out
and uh our director john crowley and
we're just having some tea or something
and
he goes
i would have made made a great pope
i would have been very lenient
and so martin mcdonough heard that it's
just out of nowhere out of nowhere and
he put that
in the movie seven psychopaths oh chris
watkins says that that's awesome and
we're high on mushrooms in the movie
when he says that wow so martin took
that so like that's must have been like
well where else how else does this make
sense they'd have to be on my mind
[Laughter]
the thing is he's brilliant in that film
nick of time and he's you know the thing
people forget about they think of you
know the you know the more cowbell and
the so all that sort of pulp fiction but
they they forget that he was a leading
man he back in the day you know the dead
zone yeah um the deer hunter i mean he
was a big tall good looking guy done a
lot of shakespeare he was a musical
theater guy like he was a leading man
and wasn't this you know
character yeah well who was who's still
on so you got walking and now you're yes
gary oldman is your proud who's on your
list that was fun to hang out with who's
on your ass gary oldman yeah
we spent a lot of time together last
year that was really cool to to while
you were going through the awards stuff
yeah that's the cool thing about that
award stuff is that they'll show these
reels at these things like they'll be
the palm springs film festival and
they'll show william defoe's william
defoe's
like clips from his career or gary
oldman's career i remember i remember um
there was this hollywood
award thing and we were all talking and
chatting and drinking beer and then
backstage and then
the gary oldman's clips came on
and everybody just shut up wow and we
just watched
his body of work wow and it's just it's
a slow clap at the end
it was like it was just astounding his
body your work is just astounding well i
remember this is not um drew
barrymore told me the story about uh
casting you and charlie's angels
she's a great lady she's a great lady
and she um but justine badly who was the
casting director yeah i remember having
right she drew told me that she said who
are those three guys because she saw
three different photos and justine said
i'm this is who we're considering for
this part she said well which one
you're like who am i those three and she
said well justine said they're the same
guy and there are three different
pictures of you do you know this story
it was like you from uh oh maybe green
mile
three different uh amazing yeah so when
you talk about i think a lot of you know
uh
younger generations think
which
must be weird for you think of you in
those terms the way you think about gary
oldman and will when they see you know
something like that uh
and feel the same way that you feel
about gary oldman so i think you
um
to see you still get excited about that
is is cool it means you know you're
still you haven't lost we're you and i
are film nerds we're we're theater nerds
yeah and you've had a lot of experience
now playing
more straight man leading man i've done
yeah i've done a little bit both as as
you have too and it's fun to do that
kind of dynamic do you prefer playing
like just a weirdo eccentric i mean i
think it's fun
to do both and like it depends what what
the chemistry is right i mean
you know yeah how about how is bob fosse
i mean how is that to it's very it's
very challenging this this fossy thing
i'm working with michelle williams who's
amazing um having a great time with her
and and tommy kale who did hamilton he's
great we're having a great time
the writers are great everybody's great
i think the only
thing is there's there's a lot of time
in the chair and you gotta sort of
figure that out and
um the chair you mean
on the toilet
yes
what
what um
it's long hours but it's good yeah it's
good it's it's it's really good we have
these amazing choreographers we're doing
a little dancing it's really it's cool
and you shaved your head people dancers
are like superheroes you know i shave my
head yeah these dancers you love to
dance so were you out of your do you
feel like out of your depth still are
you absolutely it's it this is a whole
new realm huh this is like you thought
you could dance and then
man this is like something else and to
learn the fosse vocabulary which
in short is like what michael jackson
did yeah in fact there's a great video
for anyone listening uh where where they
show michael jackson dancing to what i
forget what it is thriller or something
and thro yeah and then they and it's
side by side with fosse from like the
early 70s you showed me this yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i was blown away by how similar the
moves are that he he ripped up when you
say earlier michael jackson loves
flossie he wanted fossee to direct
thriller oh and um but but michael
jackson bob fussy said that michael
jackson was one of the greatest dancers
he'd seen since fred astaire gene kelly
i mean michael jackson was an amazing
dancer i was blown away by how similar
but he yeah he worshiped fosse uh
michael jackson he really yeah um was
there ever a thing you wanted to do uh
outside of acting were you ever do you
ever think like
i mean from your earliest memory was
acting
yeah i mean i just kind of got into it
accidentally
through my parents and then i didn't
really take it seriously and then when i
was an adult i got into it
and then i just started ripping people
off like dinero and and all these people
and
but do you when you were a kid when you
last see bob fosse ripped off the
nicholas brothers this amazing dance
team and fred astaire and everybody rips
off everybody yeah you know um
yeah what's your favorite movie of all
time
i mean i it depends comedic i would say
either stripes or animal house or and
then
dramatic probably cuckoo's nest or deer
hunter
off the top of my head you build
chinatown i mean there's so many it's
hard to bill murray was uh a big
influence and and specifically when you
did the way back yes we basically i
basically i i i copied him in meatballs
and walter matthew bad news bears and a
little bit of uh richard pryor and
busting loose this movie busting this
with him and cicely tyson
there were a few others i mean i'm just
thief yeah but but in in the sense that
they were so you were so kind of off the
cuff you had this kind of glib uh well
bill murray meatball specifically is
almost their relationship is almost
identical between the three and the boy
i mean that that's a pretty obvious
thing that's right he takes him under
his wing and he senses that he's been
alienated
um where where would you other than la
new york where if you could live
somewhere where would you want to live
san francisco you and i have spent some
good times there san francisco is a
great town yeah you love what about you
what about you uh i would say new
orleans austin yeah i love austin's
house there uh great you grew up in san
francisco you grew up i remember you
would show me where you know this is
where i had my first date this is where
i had uh that's where you see yeah you
were also part of a group of kids that
were like it was was it like fame were
they like yeah it was kind of a low
budge fame but it was also inner city
kids from everywhere so there were the
the the kids from the mission was it
intimidating
very intimidating i mean i got beat up a
lot as a kid i mean there were a lot but
there the rich kids would come in and
commute to the school of the arts but it
was still a public school so it was very
um eclectic group yeah very eclectic
very interracial very
um
uh financially the kids were all in
different places huh uh it wasn't like
just rich it was like a lot of poor kids
a lot of like
middle class it was very eclectic so so
and and and it was cool to be a a um an
artist yeah but the artist part was only
i'd say
like 20 percent of the school so the
rest was a public school
or maybe maybe maybe more than that but
like you know but margaret cho came
that's right and and uh you should tyler
yeah yeah so were your friends then
mostly actors did you yeah i mean
you know aisha and i dated for a while
and and we were an improv troupe with
margaret and uh
yeah so san fran and you would you would
live there uh music what do you listen
to to relax do you get into music on set
uh
and yeah
that's what i figured um
what do you listen to i listened to i
remember listening to m war during snow
angels i was listening to m ward uh i do
you do that depending on the character
you like to switch yeah i don't know
what's fascinating now fossey's kind of
like uh
fuzzy yeah
uh hey big spender yeah out of loop on a
loop
life could be a dream
if you had to be one age for the rest of
your life what would you pick physically
i think 40 was physically the peak oh
really that's so good to know i think 40
was really really that's cool and then
after that it was starting to fall apart
and
now i mean i'm pretty good shape now but
it it's still it's never going to be the
same after 40. 40 is like a great
and mentally 40 is a great age to be oh
that's so good i really like for being
40. oh i'm glad to hear that uh vanilla
chocolate uh i guess chocolate dogs cats
uh dogs sweet savory oh a savory
mosquitoes bees
oh bees who likes mosquitoes ugh
mosquito what are mosquitoes good for oh
get them
control
maybe that that's about it uh wine beer
oh i like them both that's really i like
but i'm kind of a snob oh this was a
question for the people i thought i for
sure thought you were gonna say beer i'd
say beer but i'm i love a good sam is a
rolo too man i love it yeah you are you
are the the
the biggest beer snob i think i've ever
known i am snob is an inherently
negative word isn't it yeah i mean
you're an a
i'm a an elitist a beerus beer yes yeah
you love trying the different ones yeah
i'm surprised okay well uh some subway
cab oh i like the subway yeah if there's
if there's no if there's no if there's
no if there's no traffic i like a cab i
love breezing through uh the brooklyn
bridge how is it now do people have you
been getting rec is it people coming up
to you more i mean it's the same
kind of stuff i think uh you know it's
always like really it's mostly really
nice i think except
if you're in a hurry right right isn't
that sort of the the one time you're
like if you're in a hurry i know but not
the best thing but if it's great if
you're if you're not if you're not in a
hurry it's great i mean you can pretty
much
it's mostly good i would say mostly good
yeah i remember the one time i was in a
hurry this was right when things started
i started
acting and things that people were
seeing and um
i was late for a train in grand central
yeah and this guy came up to me and i've
been getting a lot of like did we go to
school together like it's killing me
where do i know you from i still do we
all get that yeah and so i would say oh
where'd you go to school oh oregon oh i
went to school in connecticut but what
do you do for a living and eventually
get to the point where like oh i saw you
in a thing whatever yeah so i'm i'm
running for a train and this guy comes
up to me goes
did we go to school together and i was
like and i was late in my defense so i
was like and i said
no i'm an actor you probably know me you
probably saw me in something and he goes
oh really where were we in and i started
listing you know my at the time really
limited resume i was like this that no
no what about this no and he goes
did you grow up in fairfield connecticut
i said yeah i did
riverfield elementary school yeah i did
go there i not only did i know him but
we had been friends in first grade and
he moved out of town it was so
embarrassing and i said oh you oh and
here i am like i don't know i'm gonna
you probably know me from my work
and we were friends in first grade and
the worst part was he goes oh sir you're
acting now
it's cool you know
i do occasionally get people
there was a really sweet sometimes who
the hell do you think you are
i got one recently which was a really
sweet girl and she was like that was
really nice like oh my god you're the
guy who was in the thing i said yeah and
she said what do you do now and i said
oh well
you know
still acting she goes huh
that's kind of fun in a way though and
sometimes it's kind of fun because it's
like yeah you could be anybody now yeah
um
beetles stones
oh [ __ ] what is these these that's not a
fear these are quick these are just
don't think about um stones right today
but maybe beetles tomorrow god that's it
okay that's right spring fall
uh uh
fall god you guys you're playing some
tough ones sunrise is sunsets
sunrise your epitaph what do you want it
to read or do you want you call me
uh a racial epitaph uh what what what
wait what epitape what is an epitome for
that for your tombstone uh yes um
uh
he
um
he
no rock unturned i guess would be that's
good maybe that's it that's good uh and
is there a real person that you want to
play you've now played bush fosse
uh i i dare i say this i chuck barris i
i kind of the only person i kind of but
i'm too old
is elvis presley i'd love to play elvis
presley but
but i wouldn't you love to play elvis
presley you could play all of a sudden
vince vaughn could play you could play a
version of elvis a version of him i
guess kind of like that spider-verse
thing colin farrell a virgin of him
colin farrell played i mean he should
play elvis yeah and i think vince vaughn
should play those make sense yeah okay
maybe you and i shouldn't
you sh you could play elvis i don't know
if i should play all this but uh
somebody said on twitter cinephile femme
said
this is a good question and i'm curious
about this myself what went through your
mind when you accidentally dropped an
f-bomb in that hilarious snl oh that was
panic yeah
i played through i mean i was oh you
would never know i played through but it
was it was definitely like i thought i
was like gonna be in trouble and then
were you at all did they say anything no
they were like don't do that again but
basically but playfully yeah it was like
you know right um
a girl named kylo wants you to say hi to
her hey how's it going
okay that's good um and then this was
interesting um
it's people are asking about california
so much man i love you people ask about
galaxy quest sequel
is it gonna happen without alan yes well
they're that's right we were almost
gonna do it right they were yeah yeah
i think they're still thinking about it
you know
i it's a tough i don't know excuse to
phil what a great guy i know alan was
going to do
yeah and alan
he was such a great he was such a
beautiful guy yeah another one on galaxy
course who i didn't i didn't know anyone
and he was
he was also very kind to me when we did
that and i did a play that he he was
leaving so i took over for
and and he wrote me a he didn't have he
wrote me a letter it was a really nice
letter and i opened i was like excited
it was from alan rickman i opened it and
the card just said it was a beautiful
like sunset background and in in like
very small like ornate cursive it just
said
[ __ ] you that's awesome
well you know he helped me with um
charlie's angels a little bit oh oh
that's right you talked to him about die
hard schreiber yeah yeah but you want to
talk about that well i gave him the
script and he said just i said i want to
do all these things and this you know i
don't know maybe i said like i want to
have a cape or something
and he's like keep it simple fangs he's
i i he says um
in die hard i killed someone and then i
ate a sandwich that's right and i was
like oh yeah he says keep it simple and
that's right i remember that and he took
the time to read the script and there
were like 17 versions of that script but
he read the script and
that was very nice and he's right that
that that was that is something that's
it's nice to get help from your friends
and he was a very as a very prestigious
friend to have at that time and yeah
it's good to have you and i help each
other yeah you gave me the best advice
on uh when we were doing that play
sam and i were doing a play and and um
we had both had movies we were about to
go do yeah and yours was heist the david
mamet movie which was and so i would
read lines you were doing jupiter's
creepers i was about to go to cheapest
creepers it's a really good film a
really scary film well at the time you
know i i felt really like uh
intimidated by the
not intimidating we were reading these
great david mamet lines you know i was
helping you study and and and then we
would read mine and i was kind of i
remember being kind of down on it
because compared to the mammoth script
it was like
you know these were getting chased by
this monster and yeah the dialogue
wasn't quite as uh scintillating yeah so
and i was i remember being a little like
self-deprecating about it and you said
to me
and you were you said you got to treat
this like it's hamlet do you remember
that yeah yeah yeah i think i do
remember we were living in the house in
williamstown yeah yeah it was a really
great lesson and i'll never forget it
because you know no matter how what the
script is like you know no matter how
who
you know you still have to be that
committed to it you're great in that
movie and that movie's rocking it's
scary as [ __ ] yeah thanks it's really
terrifying that phone but you're you're
you go there you know it's like it's a
good lesson to commit you know that you
commit to it like it's something and i
was i guess pretentious at the time
where i thought like things had to be if
it wasn't
whatever it was a really good um it was
a good lesson i thank you for that just
in terms of working with people who
now if you were to put together like a
who what play would you do what what uh
you know what you do you want a
shakespeare you want to do
that's a good question um i don't know
what i'd love to do like streetcar on
film or something sometimes you don't
get those characters in film you know
what you do yeah neil simon or tiffany
williams or martin mcdonald you know
those are great words what what kind of
part would you like to play
i just want to do that no that's i'm
doing the part
i want to do that in a movie
what would you what would you do um what
would you do what would you do you know
the the i i'm getting to do a part now
that i never thought i'd get to play a
guy who's um
deeply flawed and he's a real fuck-up
and and uh and that's a lot of fun uh
this is a good that's intense this is
somebody wanted to know on twitter as
well um if they could make us if you
could green light a sequel to any movie
that you've already done
jesus um safe men
oh god that'd be great so safe men for
for
you guys who hasn't who haven't seen it
um
it's with steve zahn and um great cast
mark ruffalo's in it that would be the
one okay definitely no question safer
men safer men
coming to a theater near you i would
definitely see it and who was the great
director who did that they go john
hammer grab your tights and
i don't know that that that
this is safer men um somebody
and then the third one is the safest man
that this is somebody who this is a good
question this is agnes this is a cool
name agnes de savagni i hope i'm saying
that right i'm probably not
the first time i saw sam rock well i'm
going to do my impression of i i won't
this is the first time i saw san marco
that's exactly how i got that's a pretty
good agnes impression absolutely uh it
was in time to chillers box of moonlight
not only did sam steal every scene even
playing opposite john turturro but he
played them all wearing a buckskin suit
i wonder this is agnes but i also wonder
how much that outfit informed his
character and other costumes since
that's a good question pros to buckskin
yeah
great in the cold not so great in the
heat
um huh pros and cons wearing buckets so
it wasn't like you put that on and
you're like god now i'm like this feral
cause you played this real like feral
like country bumpkin kind of guy that
was a great uh tom dicillo did a cool we
we decided to put like a little bird
turd
on his outfit i don't know if you can
see it it's really that was a funny idea
it's just funny to hear that bird
there's a little like white bird turn on
his cat on his buckskin davy crockett
outfit but yeah that was just a really
fun wait what just as i watched gary
busey for that i remember watching gary
busey for that and something where i
thought gary bc had this energy i saw
this movie he did where he played this
like hunter or something huh
and there's this kind of false bravado
that that character has bucky has this
weird oh wow and then he uh tom chill
told me to watch um joe buck in midnight
couch oh sure yeah so when i initially
did i did it with a southern accent they
said to cut the southern accent
but dude just this innocent this kind of
like child like
you know uh yeah that thing that joe
buck had and yeah midnight cowboy like
sense of wonder kind of like yeah yeah
why
yeah why would you abandon yeah yeah so
who's left who who have you not who are
the greats that you you've yet to well
i'd love to work with meryl streep
that's right i'd love to i'd love to get
a chance to work with meryl streep
sometime and well i'm sure she's a bunch
of people she's probably holly hunter is
a great actress you know yeah i'm sure
she's yeah oh girls should be thinking
merrell's listening
i would assume she is yeah
um are you excited for you might be
nominated for more things are you is
that are you looking forward to was that
are you looking forward to going through
that again or is it i mean i know
they're pros and cons it's it's it's fun
it's a fun those are fun parties yeah
and then it's it's a lot of
you know it's scary yeah to you know but
isn't it like now
is it scary now because you've done it
you've already been through you won one
by the way where is that what do you do
with that thing i have it right here oh
yeah carry with me
guys guys you can't see this but sam's
got it around his neck
he's made a gold shame no i you know
that stuff is so
sort of beautiful and crazy and scary
it's such a great that's such a weird
thing you know and i remember phil
talked about that with us yeah one time
remember he talked about yeah you know
how much it uh the downside to it that
the stuff that you don't really consider
when yes because everybody wants one
everybody even if they say it's not
about awards yeah and i was having one
of those moments where i had been
nominated for this thing or they was
talking and i was embarrassed to reveal
that to him because i was like he was
above that you know somebody like that
no that's right we talked that's right
remember that um and he was very cool
about talking about that stuff he was
very candid and very honest and um but
but yeah so i wonder
uh how it changes and if you're looking
forward to that or or is it like well if
it happens it happens and it's cool but
it's it's it's also
you know like how do you make it you
know it's hard to make a competition out
of there's no there's no as steve's on
there's no finish line yeah um
should we make out yeah well we already
did but i guess we can again
um we i guess we have been for the last
hour and
[Laughter]
uh
man thanks hey man uh you know i'm just
gonna say one thing
uh about all that award stuff and i said
it to you recently yes but
you know i've seen people go through
different phases and i've been through
one you go through changes things happen
you get a little celebrated you go ebbs
and flows and all that um
you haven't changed and that's like a
crazy thing and i want people to know
that i want people to know um
that that could have really you know
what's your name again
[ __ ]
shia labeouf i love your work um but
thanks
i love you
and thank you guys for listening and uh
you know i love i love this man i love
you man hopefully hopefully there'll be
more
there maybe be more yeah maybe we'll
follow this up you'll be my guest every
[Music]
welcome to uh the portion of the show
called that just happened
it's not really called that show i'm
saying that ironically but it it may in
fact end up being called that
or i mean
i can't even that time you interviewed
sam rockwell
so that time i interviewed sam rockwell
what did you think of it
i picture you like doing like a macaulay
culkin like hands to the face
um
i know that you were nervous going into
that i was nervous it was weird to be
nervous talking to a friend but i will
say i don't think it showed i guess you
are an actor you were good at i was
acting with my friend i was acting i was
nervous but i was acting like i wasn't
nervous this is a perfe this is like a
really good indication of um who sam is
this is a really good it's not much of a
story but sam used to live on an
apartment just off uh on 8th street off
of 6th avenue and there's this tiny
little i couldn't have been more than
like 300 square feet tiny and uh slept
on a futon and he would always be like
come on over you should you must sleep
over and and so which meant he'd want
you to have the futon and he would sleep
in like a sleeping bag on the floor
um and there were boxes of sam love
cereal cereal all lined up
and he had the walls were just like
covered with um photos photos of his
friends that's sam's family and
when he finally moved into a bigger
apartment the decorations and the walls
became the same photos that he had all
smushed together in the old apartment
just like spread out so there'd be one
every like three feet like a photo of
one of his friends uh it was really
charming were the cereal boxes spread
out too no because the kitchen was the
same size
it had a small kitchen uh but he loved
and and then like movie memorabilia you
know he's really into in fact he got me
one of the few things in my apartment
which is a poster of the flamingo kid he
got matt dillon to sign it for me
but i know i think that story is really
important because it illustrates
who he is and how he hasn't changed i
think that's it's it's a really good
example of uh
you know it's not a great story but no
no
but it's a good indicator because you
know after all his success and you know
making more money and all that right
he's still he can go out and buy like
fancy he still has the same friends and
yeah he didn't like trade up and and
start hanging out with like uh
you know yeah who knows you know
yeah with the dalai lama yeah yeah um
yeah which we've both seen i mean i've
seen that happen to people i know and uh
yeah to the point where he is um
yeah it's bizarre how little he's
changed uh and a testament to
what
his character there's something so
innocent about sam yeah i noticed this
uh and and this is not a visual medium
so i don't know if this will translate
but i was watching the interview and i
and i've noticed this about him before
when he's talking to someone he has this
way of like st studying their face and
their expressions and and i can see him
he like shows his lower i can see him
yeah i can see him uh digesting
someone's countenance you know and
someone's mannerisms and he's such a
like a student of people and you could
see him he's like a sponge of human
behavior which which again he you know
he in that in the interview i thought it
was so interesting how much he talks
about how he steals from the great
actors from de niro and all these people
but i see him steal from from just
random people that he's talking to in a
way
i wonder if you real how much of that he
realizes
you could see him sort of like
really confused it's just zoning in on
on someone's face yeah you know and he
has sort of like a little smirk
when he's unsure of something yeah yeah
yeah you're doing it really well right
now well and i i wish you guys could see
this but i find myself doing it too i
have a similar i i've stolen things from
sam i mean i listened to sam from sam
yeah yeah weird
tremendous i mean
especially when i'm around he has such a
unique
he has such a unique cadence i think
like christopher walken i mean i think
they're
they're similarly unique yeah oh my god
i mean a lot of it is
oh my god it's tremendous yeah
oh yeah he's he's he's also and
sometimes when i have outbursts of uh
oh my oh my god like that's sam you know
yeah yeah yeah when he's listening it's
oh my god yeah we're not fully listening
you know like kind of instead of
listening fully to the question he's
he's studying so the way that someone's
saying something that's what struck me
it was it almost seemed like at times
you was
more aware of how you were
saying the question then what the
content of the question was you know
what i mean and he gets this like
knowing yeah yeah he's got this sort of
innocence about him you know he's got
this
which i found interesting that he he
said that the age that he
his body
pick forever would be 40 because he
always struck me as someone like such a
peter pan someone who's so sort of
innocent and
um again which i'm sure helps his acting
that he has this he's this sort of open
book this sort of like has this naive
spirit about him yeah there's also um he
embraces
moments sam is very good at being
i feel like
was like that i mean but both of them
share this they have um
they laugh with real abandon when they
find something funny they've i mean phil
had this laugh that was just uh i mean
he he laughed the way he acted i mean he
just was like complete and pure and like
honest honest so uh i can't thank him
enough for having done that and um thank
you guys for listening i hope you
enjoyed that
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
thank you for listening to life is short
if you like the show please give us a
five star review at least four stars and
tell your friends to subscribe uh we're
available on apple podcast spotify
google podcasts and every major
listening app as well as wandery.com our
theme song is performed by our friend
harmar superstar life is short is hosted
by me justin long produced by christian
long and megan monaco senior producers
michelle lanz executive produced by
marcia louis and ernan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
i've said a lot of gross things in my
life but i've heard a lot of gross
things but i have never obsessed with
you how can you be so
no
i mean
wouldn't you think i would have heard of
that oh it makes my ass water you yes no
it really makes my ass i remember you
saying make my bladder bleed or your
brother or someone otherwise oh who else
would i would say that in front of me
in in the sense that i'm like like
sarcastically
i don't even know what it means what
does that mean my ass water like
it makes me so happy but what does that
mean i don't know i wouldn't have said
something like that without if i didn't
even know what it meant oh yes you did i
would be about you particular or maybe
it was this oh get out of here i didn't
i i i've never even i don't know what it
means
to have a watery ass is not a good thing
you